the Grand Theft Auto 6 trailer pulled
some iconic viral Florida social media
moments and put them in the game I
actually didn't know about any of these
I guess I don't spend enough time on
Florida internet I don't know but screen
time on Twitter has compiled a list of a
bunch of them including this lady with
two hammers this was an actual news
story of a guy having to get an
alligator a crocodile I don't know out
of a local swimming pool this is a woman
twerking on top of a car which wow only
in Florida and then you've got this
naked man who I guess was under arrest
he has seen running through a parking
lot and the subreddit seems to have also
found the mud go this is speculative
obviously but it looks pretty spot on
that's the Florida video that's the
trailer based on the tongue I would
think it's probably her